so right now I think there's a unique
opportunity for Christian content
creators when it comes to YouTube and
social media and in this video I just
wanted to actually share just kind of
from the heart as well as get into six
things I wrote down and a bunch of
different Bible verses that I think we
need to know as Christians now as you
might know think media podcast our brand
think media we help people with cameras
and YouTube and we have a Divergent
audience with diverse beliefs and
backgrounds and business owners and all
kinds of people but our message
definitely resonates with those that
would say you know I'm a Christian and
I've got some that's that's my uh Faith
personally and so I really have some
powerful things I want to share that I
think will be valuable to you and
um you know if if you're uh not a
Christian then you may not want to watch
this video but you're certainly welcome
here as well so
um you know Billy Graham said that I
believe one of the next great moves of
God is going to be through Believers in
the marketplace
and I think that there's a massive
opportunity right now if you have a
message a business if you're a Christian
business owner a Christian content
creator uh Kingdom entrepreneur to
really lean in because there's massive
opportunity happening specifically with
YouTube and for Content creators and so
um let's dive into some of the thoughts
that I wrote down but number one is we
were created to create
um you know God is a Creator and what's
fascinating to me is the fifth word in
the Bible is God revealing himself as a
Creator it says in the beginning God
created how crazy is it that the first
thing that God revealed about himself
was not that he was loving was not that
he was holy was not any of these other
things but that he was a Creator and
ultimately being made in the image of
God the Hebrew word for that is Bara and
it's to create to shape and deform you
know what we do as content creators is
we're making something out of nothing
we're using our phones and cameras we
are telling stories we're building
businesses
we are launching uh products we're
creating something I believe we are most
like our uh we are looking like God
created in God's image when we are
creating and you were created to create
God is a maker you were created to make
and build something and so I think that
now is a massive time if you've had
something stunning in your heart to
share
um something to put out there in the
world this would be the time to jump in
what are you waiting for what's holding
you back and by the way I'm going to be
doing Q a here
um in a little bit towards the end and
um smash like if you're getting value
and uh let's go number two we have a we
were given a mission from Jesus
um the Great Commission says therefore
go and make disciples of all Nations
baptizing them in the name of the Father
the Son of the Holy Spirit and teaching
them to obey everything I commanded you
as surely I'm with you always to the
very end of the age
here's what I want to lean in on
teaching them to obey everything I
commanded you you know when Jesus said
this at the end of The Book of Matthew
the question was well what did he teach
and what did he tell what it what what
was the content of that you know fast
forward to today we have the full Bible
the full Canon
and it's all inspired but in the context
of this quote from Jesus he's referring
to some things that were just shared
over the previous months and years and
he was like these are the things you
should teach Everybody by the way the
Great Commission is not just for a
pastor for a church it's for anybody
that would call themselves a Christ
follower
so what I think this is so important for
Content creators number one we were
created to create number two we were
given a mission from Jesus
is
it is my conviction that this isn't just
for Christian that that the only type of
content creators representing Jesus
should be creating Christian content
fair in fact sometimes people are like I
just I didn't even really know Sean that
you were a Christian
um that kind of surprised me because you
know I didn't hear you talk about it or
something and the reason was that for
that had a lot to do with the fact that
I don't do Christian camera reviews I
don't believe there's such a thing you
know what I mean like what does it make
sense you just do camera reviews I think
there's something about
being able to be Salt and Light if you
do have a Bible study Channel A
discipleship Channel you're you're
creating Christian content that's
overtly Christian that's amazing but I
think there's a lot of opportunity and
so when Jesus said hey teach
disciples Go Make Disciples and teach
them everything I commanded you what are
some of the stuff that Jesus taught well
from an overview I looked at Matthew and
looked through the gospels he taught
stuff like don't be angry with people
so when I think about the power of
starting a YouTube channel we can start
a YouTube channel around so many
different niches or backgrounds or
topics so there could be there could be
personal development channels right he
taught have integrity in your sexuality
you tell each about relationships you
could talk about YouTube channels but
about these different areas of life this
is probably the most overtly
scripture-based video I've ever done but
like you don't you don't got to be
quoting scripture necessarily to teach a
Biblical worldview or to share the
highest level principles that exist in
the created universe created by God
which would be the very word of God so
what else he said let your yes be yes
and your no be no be people of your
world your word so in business like a
business Channel that's the number one
business first in the Bible I think is
let your yes be yes and your no be no
so like make a promise and deliver on
your promise can you imagine I went to
the restaurant they promised me the food
would be good it was good I gave them
five stars on Yelp the restaurant blew
up I made a promise as a Christian coach
to deliver a result someone hired me I
delivered the result they gave me a
great review like that's like the number
one verse of business so so just this
idea that there could be
emotional intelligence channels you know
personality tests you could be talking
about relationships you could be talking
about business don't retaliate when
you're wrong love your enemies give to
the needy opportunities for non-profits
or philanthropic efforts uh make your
business about more than money
helping people life coaches helping
people navigate life and go to a deeper
level because if if life was only about
money right then we'll end up with an
empty life
um don't judge others
um pray don't be anxious or worry uh do
unto others as you'd have them do unto
you be careful with who you partner with
these are just like a couple quick
overviews of the stuff that Jesus taught
on so it's like when I think about
people in our community it's like we can
have RV channels and DIY channels and
artistic channels and business channels
and personal finance channels what's
interesting is that's all in there Jesus
taught on all that stuff right and so
number two is we were given a mission
and I think there's a unique opportunity
for Christian content creators to
fulfill the mission of Jesus in some
cases start a Bible study Channel that's
amazing you know start a channel for
your church but on the other hand too we
can fulfill the Great Commission partly
with YouTube
with social media right I think that's a
massive opportunity
let's go to number three number three we
are called to be Salt and Light
check out this from the message
paraphrase this verse in Matthew 5 14-16
it says this here's another way to put
it you're here to be light bringing out
the god colors in the world God is not a
secret to be kept we are going public
with this as public is a city on a hill
if I make you light bearers and you
don't think I'm gonna hide you under a
bucket do you I'm putting you on a light
stand now that I've put you on a Hilltop
on a light stand shine keep an open
house be generous with your lives by
opening up to others you'll prompt
people to open up with God this generous
Father in heaven and I love that you are
here to be light and to bring out the
god colors in the world
so if you've got you want to build a
brand you want to create a merch line
you want to launch music you want to
inspire people with creativity you want
to help bullet journals you're here to
bring out the god colors in the world to
help people in like the NIV it talks
about your Salt and Light a city on a
hill not to be hidden so that people
would see your good works and praise
your father in Heaven question is how
can they see your good works if you're
not uploading videos
how can they see good works if you get
distracted or you get discouraged and
you get sidelined and you're not posting
what would it look like if we were
creating content that brought the god
colors out in the world
and you know there's a old like saying
that it's better to Light One Candle
than to curse the darkness and our
conviction kind of at think media I know
there's all different expressions of
Christianity is sometimes I get a little
uncomfortable though when Christians are
just known for what they're against and
not for what they're for
when they're just known for maybe
picketing in front of places and
criticizing things they don't agree with
while maybe you feel called to that
that's between you and God but I think
the big opportunity is rather than
cursed the darkness
it's better to Light One Candle what
does that mean
there's a book called Next Christians by
Gabe Lyons and it talks about the way to
actually shape culture is not to curse
culture but it's to create more culture
so if you want to really influence the
music industry it's not to just be like
oh that music is bad it's you go make
some good music if you really want to
influence the YouTube world or the
social media world go make the best
content in the world actually light a
candle upload some content now I know
that there's a time and place for
ideas uh idea Wars debates
um you know speaking directly to
different ideologies and World Views and
I'm all for it if you feel called to
political places or all these different
things but there's just such a massive
opportunity for you to be Salt and Light
and to go public with this and to shine
like a city on a hill and I think this
makes people uncomfortable because some
people especially Christians they're
like I just don't want to promote myself
it's a good it's a good point because we
need to be humble right but there's a
difference between toxic ambition or
selfish ambition and godly ambition and
if your Godly ambition is that God would
be glorified through your works that
you'd bring out the god colors in the
world that you recognize there's a lot
of evil and there's a lot of falsehood
and there's a need of Truth and there's
a need of beauty and there's a need of
God's wisdom being brought into the
world
that's a pretty good reason to shine
bright so those that's a good reason to
try to go viral that's a good reason to
try to get subscribers it's a good
reason and it's literally a command like
Jesus is like yo you need a shine
brighter yeah you need to you need to
you're a city on a hill I'm not trying
to hide you like you are light bearers
um ultimately not so that we'd have
glory for ourselves but that we could
give glory to God right and so we are
called to be Salt and Light and as you
may know salt is a preserving agent you
know sometimes people go man social
media is pretty dark there's a lot as a
father now with a two and a half year
old and a six month old oh social
media's got a lot of Darkness on it fair
enough and you should
definitely be thoughtful and for
yourself or for your family or for your
kids but why and the reason I wanted to
make this video too is just because as a
Christian myself this is I'm very
familiar with this world been in church
for the last a lot of years you know
maybe since 2003 or 20 years or
something like really in church so I've
been Christian for a while and and
certain mindsets I'll see as people
hesitate oh I just want to be humble I
don't I don't know if that's real
humility it's probably false humility
because meanwhile God's calling you to
shine and they go do something and build
something and reach someone and impact
someone
and that sometimes we don't uh we need a
preserving agent Salt
is a preserving agent where oh social
media is so dark well then why don't you
light a light
to to stand for truth to to counteract
if people are creating other culture and
a lot of people trying to cancel
Christian voices
um it seems to be that it's not a very
popular those that are convicted with
Christian values are not very popular in
culture these days
um but ultimately it is our
responsibility understanding that that's
just going to be what it is and what
shocks me is people get mad when
Christians share their point of view but
a lot of people aren't getting mad when
other people share their point of view
I'm a free speech person
that's why I think it's it's everybody's
freedom to create YouTube videos it's
your tube so this is a message an Urgent
Message to you as a Christian content
creator or someone who's aspiring to do
that plenty of other people are being
very loud about their beliefs their
values
their World Views and that's their
choice to do and I respect their freedom
to do that because that's what Free
Speech really is here's my question
where are the Christians
where are where everybody else is being
loud sharing their world view and that's
their free will to do that
why aren't you
you're called to be salt light to shine
and it has been every once in a while
someone catches Vision in our community
like man it'd be really awesome if there
was like more positive content more
uplifting maybe you feel like you're
called to be a kids Creator now that I
have my son who watches YouTube kids I'm
like we need I was talking to Griffin
Fox this weekend at church about this
just hanging out outside in Las Vegas
and and he was like I was like bro you
could really create some amazing kids
content he's been in kids ministry and
all this stuff and I was like but we
don't need just like one channel
creating like great children's content
we need thousands like there do you
understand how big there's 2.6 billion
monthly active users on YouTube right
now there's 50 billion monthly shorts
views being consumed YouTube kids is
this massive app
and again
well I don't necessarily agree or
there's plenty of stuff I don't agree
with
I believe it's their freedom to upload
it is everybody's freedom to upload
whatever content they want according to
YouTube's Community guidelines right and
so rather than spend all this time
analyzing and calculating how dark the
world is
I'm just I'm just challenging us
together and myself why don't we light a
candle
why don't we go start creating great
content so if you're just joining uh my
name is Sean Cannell rhymes with YouTube
channel and uh uh what's funny and
cheesy but true
um and we're talking about six things uh
that I've kind of discovered in
Scripture that I think we need to know
as Christian content creators
um
and that could be that you have a a
Bible study Channel or it could just be
that you're a business owner a content
creator an entrepreneur you're building
a personal brand you're a minister
you're a pastor who wants to get your
message out there or something
um and and you may be overtly you know a
Christian Channel or you may just be
like a faith-based person who's really
also saying you know how can I use
YouTube and social media to spread
messages that matter or to just build my
business to solve Pro entrepreneur solve
problems for a profit so how can I weave
this into my business and I think the
opportunity is and I'll do some q a here
in a while and thanks for being here
live Zeb I see you and skelke and I see
you Sharon and Anthony and Brandon and
Zeb
um that's right Pastor Trey VanCamp we
need thousands to of us to press upload
to the glory of God I agree 100 percent
okay so
um
number one we were created to create you
were created in the image of God
the fifth word in the Bible is in the
beginning God created the first thing
God revealed about himself was that he
was a Creator and you were made in His
image you got to press record uh we were
given a mission by Jesus one to teach
everything he commanded and he taught on
everything so there's an opportunity for
channels from a Christian worldview or a
judeo-christian values world view
There's an opportunity for business
channels and motherhood channels and
family channels and parenting channels
and education channels and arts and
entertainment and media and all these
different things and that's a mission
not just to
pastors
or somebody that's in vocational
Ministry it's a mission to you if you
would say I'm a Christian then you're
called Mark 16 15 says go into all the
world and preach the good news to all
creation
what's a better way to preach the good
news to all creation
then YouTube with with the distribution
from your home from my home office here
in Las Vegas I'm able to connect with
174 people on here live and if you're
watching this on the replay hit me with
replay fam in the comments number three
we're called to be Salt and Light
um and uh we'll get into number four in
just a second but I also want to remind
you
that if you haven't heard about it next
week we're doing a three-day YouTube
challenge to 1kchallenge.com and uh link
is in the description as well I'll come
back to that in a little bit let's get
into number four we need to scale up
this is a message to Christian content
creators number four we need to scale up
let me give you some verses Daniel
chapter 1 verse 5. so you might know
Daniel and the Lion's Den Daniel Meshach
Shadrach Abednego Daniel chapter one
they're setting the context and
um
the King King Nebuchadnezzar is looking
for young men to serve in the palace to
serve as his advisors to be a part of
government to be a part of influence
and these Hebrews her who are in Exile
at the time Daniel Meshach Shadrach and
Abednego get selected for this but
that's what I find fascinating is they
were trained for three years and after
that they entered the King's Service
it's interesting about this is these
guys were trained this wasn't Bible
College
this was training
in the ways of Babylon in terms of
government
I think there's something that
Christians struggle with when it comes
to like
looking for overly sanitized information
when as Christians we need the skill of
eating the mo the eating the meat and
throwing out the bones
Moses learned all the different skill
sets in Egypt
so if of course we need discernment and
we have to be
careful and we have to be thoughtful and
we have to have a filter that we filter
everything of course Through the Bible
but what's fascinating to me is these
guys Meshach Shadrach and Abednego they
skilled up and Daniel they had three
years of training
this wasn't like
yeah I'm kind of dabbling on my content
creation skills it's kind of it's kind
of dabbling learning here and there
listen to think my idea podcast every
once in a while this is training for
three years but then here's what's
fascinating Daniel chapter 1 verse 20.
whenever the king consulted them in any
matter requiring wisdom and balanced
judgment he found them 10 times more
capable than any of the magicians and
enchanters in the entire Kingdom
this was the original 10x man Grant
Cardone didn't come up with 10x Daniel
did right uh and and there's a lot of
people with 10x like this is so so the
king consulted them they went through
the same training that everybody else
went through but you should expect as a
Believer if you're a Christian content
creator you should be persuaded and
convicted that he who is in you is
greater than he is in the world
that you have
God's super on your natural that you
have access to the gifts of the Spirit
that you have access to the word of God
the best
besides the gospel and a rule of Truth
and and the Canon of scripture it's also
the greatest success book ever written
it's also the greatest book for Content
creators ever written
like anything you could ever need in
here it's better than any self-help book
better than any
trending Business book and I read a lot
of books like and and I think that's the
lifestyle of the Christian content
creator youth spending three years in
Babylon you like Moses spending time in
Egypt but then also just knowing that
that that culture did not influence
Daniel influenced the culture lived a
little bit of a different lifestyle had
a different diet prayed three times a
day but also was trained number four is
you gotta skill up
like if you are a Christian content
creator
you got to go a little bit deeper at
times than just like I'm just gonna pray
and my channel is going to grow and I
know like that's not what you think but
that's how some people like if it's
God's will my channel will go um
actually God's will is that you would
skill up like God's will is that you
take responsibility God's will is that
you would meditate on the law Joshua
chapter one
so that in doing so you may prosper in
all your ways that when you would skill
up and learn skills and develop your
skills and abilities the horses prepared
for the day of battle but Victory
Belongs to the Lord there's something
that you have a responsibility in to
skill up and these guys skilled up but
then when God super came on their
natural
there's these magicians these enchanters
and in every matter requiring wisdom and
balance judgment King Nebuchadnezzar
found them more capable 10x so
so I just think there's going to be a
revolution I think we're already in it
it's cool to see different people that
are creating content you know Alan Parr
and Ruslan and Isaiah and I got some
other friends right now I got some
people that have been growing with
shorts like crazy
um and these are like Christian channels
but then you also have like you'd be
shocked I'm in a mastermind of of
Christian Business Leaders people you
don't even know that are in places of
influence and with with leaders of all
different backgrounds like God is up to
something on the earth it's it's pretty
incredible and the opportunity for us as
Christian content creators is to take
Skilling up seriously but then also to
entrust the whole thing man will make
his plans God will direct our steps
entrust your work to the Lord and He
will uh help it prosper and so there's
something about Skilling up and leading
into the supernatural uh Proverbs 22 29
says
um
I don't know I posted the wrong
scripture there
let's look it up I'm on a Google doc
here
you see someone who's so diligent in
business they'll stand before Kings not
before Common men
let me give you a different version of
it
do you see any skilled workers truly
competent workers they received before
King they will serve before Kings not
ordinary people it's my belief that the
the lid on your content creator growth
it could be timing and sometimes like
it's it's good to use your season and
obscurity to prepare you for popularity
I just talked with my friend Nicholas
barely yesterday about the theme of
scripture being a lot slower than we
would like in terms of viral culture you
know who went viral was Saul he got
anointed king put into kingship and then
he had a horrible fall King Saul because
he didn't really have a lot of character
development time meanwhile David had
lions tigers and bears actually got
anointed so I had to wait like seven
years plus more years until he was like
fully Judah King versus Israel King you
saw Moses like passionate but made some
mistakes in his life 40 years in the
wilderness Joseph had a Clear Vision of
what he was called to but then had to
get thrown into a pit then it was like
cool I'm in Potiphar's house shooting
now I'm in prison and then eventually he
reaches sometimes it's going to take a
little bit longer to get to your destiny
right sometimes the growth of your
channel use your season and obscurity to
prepare you for popularity
but the cap ultimately on the growth of
your Channel
is that your content sucks
I mean do you see any truly competent
workers they'll serve before Kings not
common men here's the promise
that if content is King
so that when good content is posted to
YouTube and Tick Tock and Instagram
the algorithm promotes it
if you develop competency
we need to skill up
if you work on your content and I don't
I want this to be challenging
but also to be encouraging I think about
my like Sean I just discovered you
you're an overnight success yeah
overnight success just takes 20 years I
started shooting video in 2003 for my
church started the First Youtube channel
in 2007 for my church
that eventually started a business
called clearvision media worked with
different authors speakers have
different background have experience in
the business world then went back and
was the director of communications at a
church and then started thinking like
it's been a journey and we're we're
going viral in the last year we've had a
lot of viral Facebook reels we got a lot
of viral
tick tocks we've had we're going viral
right now on YouTube we got we just went
from four million views a month to
almost 10 million YouTube shorts
oh overnight success yeah it only took
20 years so there's just something about
developing competency you know the first
day also that
David met Goliath when David get met
Goliath that wasn't his first day of
using
a sling in five stones
like he wasn't like you know what I
think that based on this I can't go at
him with armor and swords and whatnot
I'm gonna go at him with a slingshot
I wish I would have learned how to use
this thing no he had been training his
whole life and preparing his whole life
for this moment of opportunity
that he stumbled into he's coming out
with the charcuterie Board of cheese and
crackers for his brothers is tending the
sheep and overhears a situation that's
going on there's something about
committing to a season of building new
skills seeing every year of your life
whether you're crushing it right now as
a content creator or you're just
starting as it's all preparation and I
am getting ready for that thing that
Vision that God has given me that
picture that God has given me punchline
is we need to skill up that's actually
one of the reasons that's actually what
we do as a company by the way and you
probably already know that we help you
learn the skills of online video of what
can't how to make your videos look
crispy Omar teaches you drippy crispy
videos how to use the platforms best
practices for using the platforms
changes in the platforms and algorithms
as well as the macro strategy not just
how do I start a channel and get some
views what good reviews if you don't
don't have a clear vision of your
business model of what is this all unto
is what is the bigger picture what are
the pieces is it bigger than YouTube am
I going to be on multiple platforms do I
need to build out a website am I
eventually building out an offer or an
email list there's a long journey and a
lot of skills to learn along the way
that's why we have our free podcast
that's why we have two YouTube channels
that's why we have our online courses
and all kinds of different things and if
you haven't heard and I just mentioned
it we are doing a free three-day YouTube
challenge it's all about how to get your
first or next 1000 subscribers to
1kchallenge.com is the URL Link in the
description as well and uh it's entirely
free
it's a Thursday Friday and Saturday
there's a morning session and an evening
evening session we have four special
guests coming on sharing their tips and
it's going to be really fun and it's
entirely free and again uh if like Sean
what's the secret behind the door number
one at the end of The Challenge and
during the challenge we will let you
know about other you can do with us I
have a book I highly recommend buying it
it's YouTube secret second edition or
don't
during the challenge we talk about our
course video record Academy I highly
recommend buying it or don't like it's
just a way of scaling up and going
faster but regardless we are committed
to helping you in on YouTube our mission
is to help 10 000 purpose-driven people
create a full-time living doing what
they love while making a difference in
the world with YouTube and online video
obviously when we help that and that's
why no matter what your backgrounds or
beliefs watching this like you're
welcome here you can belong at think
media even if you don't believe what I
believe
but we do want to help most of all our
vision is purpose-driven people and
people that are bringing good into the
world people that are light bearers you
know people that are solving problems
and you know entertaining and educating
and bringing good and we
unapologetically acknowledge that there
is evil
Satan's real it's been interesting to
see conversations between Andrew Schultz
and Joe Rogan talking about yeah Satan's
probably real like look at how much evil
there is in the world one of the
greatest
things that leads many people to Faith
is actually when evil becomes clearer
than ever they go oh shoot
there must be a god
and and we start that Faith journey and
so we want to help uh people share
messages that matter light bearers right
people that that want to be solving
problems making the world better and you
know we're passionate and so if that
sounds like something you'd be into
that's at uh tube1k challenge.com you
can register for free
um hit like if you're getting value and
I'm gonna do some q a in just a second
put four question marks before and after
your question if you have a question the
topic today
is a message to Christian content
creators and I have a meeting at
in 28 minutes so that is the maximum
that we can go today recapping number
one you were created to create if you're
made in God's image God is a Creator
it's the first thing he revealed about
himself in the Bible it's the fifth word
of Genesis
um is a Creator so it's time to create
number two we were given a mission from
Jesus teaching Everything Jesus taught
and all of scripture which might include
your DIY channel of bringing out the god
colors in the world right of art Beauty
fashion music
creativity
gardening number three you're called to
be Salt and Light number four you need
to scale up we need to scale up we need
to skill up continuously I I would shift
the camera over here let me show you I'm
gonna I'll just go for it here's here's
what I'm working on right now y'all
this is
this is my current to read list
all right
um
and the reason I throw that out there is
not because you have to read any of that
or you do whatever you want but I just
want you to to know I mean one of the
things that I just strive to create
distance from is between me and
hypocrisy nothing that makes me more
uncomfortable when someone says one
thing it doesn't live it you know and so
I I just it is my conviction and it has
been my lifestyle
that I believe that the best investment
we can make is in ourselves and then
learning new skills I believe it's also
the pattern of scripture Jesus grew in
wisdom and favor with men Jesus at 12
was found in the temple asking other
people lots of questions
having articulate questions
seeking wisdom seeking to get better
books of course is just one way
uh
online courses audiobooks podcasts it's
a lifestyle
and the lid on your YouTube channel
I said it in love
it's probably your content sucks
among other things
and so what's the opportunity how do you
solve that problem you skill up
you improve you train for three years
you go out and repeatedly throw rocks
at
glass bottles I don't know if David had
glass bottles in those days
and and increase your slingshot accuracy
week after week month after month year
over year
and then when Goliath arrives
you're able to have the precise
Target where you're able to hit this
small area in the giant's head and enter
into your destiny
sure God super comes on your natural
sure it that was a miraculous event
but it was it he prepared for that
moment where his preparation met God's
power and that's what we need to do as
contact creators as well number five
we need to be wise and pure
wise and pure what
all right here's the verse
Matthew 10 16.
look I'm sending you out as sheep among
wolves so be a shrew to snakes and as
harmless as doves this is a message to
Christian content creators
this is probably one of the most
under red or understood verses in the
Bible and no one talks about this so I'm
sending you out a sheep Among Wolves
first of all it is this idea that like
we kind of touched on this
you need to start create like you should
create content you should get on Tick
Tock you should get on YouTube you
should get out there
but but what about but social media has
some bad stuff on it yeah it's a
dumpster fire
but what do we do it's understanding
yeah there's not good people out there
there could be trolls out there there
could be hurt people out there it's like
we toxic stuff out there
you gotta have your discernment on you
gotta have your discernment on like I'm
sending you out of sheep Among Wolves
it's also not necessarily going to be
easy it's you get a face resistance
you're gonna face challenges you're
gonna face wolves
so be as shrewd as snakes
and harmless as doves what does that
mean
a couple things so
serpents never unduly expose themselves
to attack
something about being thoughtful
Sean should my content be overtly
Christian could be
maybe I feel about doing it a little bit
different I have a different style of my
content pray about it like that's like
serpents never expose themselves on
dually to attack Jesus taught in
parables
though seeing like there was a reason he
did it and without going into that like
he was thoughtful about his brand about
his messaging about the context of the
room about who is listening
right and so serpents never unduly
expose themselves to attack
they also never provoke the enemy
cunning in wisdom is another thing for
this number four is is we need to be
wise and we need to be pure as Christian
content creators so shoot as snakes what
does it mean subtle crafty shrewd wise
avoiding snares that are set up for us
Discerning the difference in audiences
Jesus would do that
storytelling to feed and weed Jesus used
storytelling for some people because by
the way too and even this training might
make some people unsubscribe or not want
to follow us which is totally fine
um but ultimately as you start sharing
your message don't be surprised you're
like I'm worried if I'm going to get
haters or what if someone disagrees with
me that is the continuous theme
of the entire Bible
if you want to be bold like Elijah you
have prophets of Baal that disagree with
you if you want to be bold like Jesus
then pretty much every room he was a
part of every context there was people
who didn't believe or got mad or got
angry or disagreed and ultimately they
imprisoned him and ultimately crucified
him and even as we share this in
uh Holy Week approaching Easter Sunday
he overcame death in the grave and he
rose again but ultimately
you've got
storytelling to be in different
situations different contexts Discerning
the differences in audiences you got to
be shrewd blunt when needed
I hope you're getting value let me know
if you have any aha moments from this
kind of a little bit different than what
we normally do
shrew to snakes
as a Christian content creator you're
called to be shrewd wise
but then he put attention on this right
wisdom does not equal Dishonored honesty
you know one of my favorite books in the
Bible probably my favorite book is the
Book of Proverbs James is the New
Testament Book of Proverbs and James
talks about wisdom not all wisdom is
Godly wisdom so shrew to serpents the
reason he's like in harmless is doves is
because wisdom does not equal dishonesty
if we think we have to be careful I
think as as Christians if falling in to
just click bait or too far into just
drama or is what we're doing just for
views or is it actually being effective
are we spending too much time creating
controversy even Within
Christians and the church or are we
actually being effective
in
reaching people and representing Christ
um wisdom does not equal dishonesty and
innocence does not equal gullibility
gotta be shrewd thoughtful careful
strategic
see you nobody most people wouldn't
think about you think about Jesus you
just present Jesus and culture it's like
yeah man just love everybody and chill
out bro you know
like it's kind of Jesus's zendow you
know it just loves people so much you
know which is true bring the little
children to me a lot of times you don't
think of like shrewd
and strategic
that's what we see here
and then innocent is doves that means
pure no self-serving agenda purity
um because dubs would be clean for
animal sacrifice according to Old
Testament and serving the lord
blamelessly
this is a message to Christian content
creators I highly encourage you to be
considerate of Matthew 10 16 as
a mode of operation for a way that you
conduct yourself with
um when it comes to creating content or
thinking about starting a channel and
how you do it and once again I want to
encourage you we need thousands and tens
of thousands of Christian content
creators sharing all different types of
content
and
just because you're a Christian content
creator doesn't mean your content has to
be Christian like it only teaches bible
study stories or something right but
storytelling
some of the best films one of the things
we're passionate about think media uh
Nolan molt worked in Hollywood
worked in La was definitely on a grind
12 14 16 hour days a lot of times like
an hour or two commute because they had
to live further out he worked as a
stagehand and a grip on different shows
and is passionate about making movies
like when we think about what we're
doing it at think media like we're still
just getting started we're you were
teaching YouTube and social media we're
doing some of this stuff but as far as
our vision and some of the people on our
team in terms of Storytelling right in
terms of
crafting Redemptive content that might
not be the chosen which is awesome
but that's a certain type of content
right
here's the message I'm trying to
encourage you with
what has God put on your heart what do
you see what's the vision you see what
is the conviction you have what is the
gap you see in the marketplace for music
or creativity or YouTube or humor or
entertainment or all of these things
what is the vision God has given you in
order to get there we got to be wise and
pure Matthew 10 16 you're going to need
to be shrewd and you're going to need to
be innocent
um I hope that's encouraging and then
number six before some q a
we need to take action we we need to
take action
and I just want to challenge you if you
felt maybe discouraged because you have
been creating content it hasn't grown I
want to encourage you
to get back in it I want to encourage
you if you haven't started Now's the
Time to start I want to encourage you
that
um uh you're needed Matthew 9 37-38 he
said to his disciples the Harvest is
great but the workers are few so pray to
the Lord who's in charge of the Harvest
ask him to send out workers into the
field
the opportunity on YouTube isn't the
problem the Harvest isn't the problem
the need isn't the problem the demand
for Christian content and family
friendly content or content that you
want your kids to watch or or gen Z and
young Millennials and Elder Millennials
and Gen X and Baby Boomers sharing and
helping and passing along wisdom to the
generations
the demand for it is there supply and
demand
the hunger for it is there the Harvest
is not the problem the workers
are the problem
people taking action
people punching fear in the face and
pressing record
people
willing to go through three years of
training to skill up
people willing to do the hard work and
to defeat The Lion and the bear and
develop the slingshot skills needed to
be ready when Goliath shows up but I
believe that's you like it'd be if
you're watching this and you clicked on
this video that you understand
that God's put something some passion on
your life you'll only be watching this
video if you wanted to create content
your faith-based your Christian
so pray
and take action
and I think there is something about
this like I think a a powerful prayer to
pray because that's the exact thing that
Jesus said in this context he's like
listen the Harvest is great the demand
on YouTube is there it's 2.6 billion
people and the platform is growing like
the Harvest is great but the workers are
few we need more channels if you feel
like it's too crowded you're wrong
we do need more content creators not
just content creators that lob stuff out
there you got to skill up you got to be
wise got to be strategic
and then I would I pray God give me a
vision give me a vision for the content
you're calling me to create help me see
the opportunity on the platform help me
discern what my unique skill gift sets
and abilities Set Me Free from any like
negative self-talk and comparison that
just puts me into paralysis because I
just feel like oh what's the big deal or
what's the need or why would anybody
care about what I have to say you got to
get rid of all that be strong and create
courageous God hasn't given you a spirit
of fear but a spirit of power love and
self discipline of a sound mind so get
into that state and then ask for more
workers into the field two things to
pray about one God give me a vision
strengthen me help me give me Clarity on
the content you've called me to create
and two God I pray for Christian content
creators those that are creating content
right now
if you are here you're a pretty unique
person obviously we probably met
sometime or we're just meeting we're
here on think media podcast you may have
been a part of this journey
but I want to implore you that's why I
wanted to shoot this video is
like to be more thoughtful
that I really do believe you're called
to creativity or else you want to be
watching this video You're called to
YouTube or else you want to be watching
this video and here's what I mean you're
you're you're passionate about this
industry you're passionate about the
Creator economy you're passionate about
messages that matter being platformed
being shared on YouTube you're probably
passionate you're passionate about Jesus
you're passionate about the Bible and
you're trying to figure out what does it
look like to be a Christian business
owner a Christian content creator or how
can I share my faith and impact the
world and change the world and solve
problems so again if that's you I want
to challenge you that God would he not
only calls us to Unique vocations I
think he calls us to unique
prayer lists
if that makes sense
like I pray
for
YouTubers
is that that's what I'm trying to say
other people don't even probably know
who they are they wouldn't think of it
makes sense this is our sphere of
influence
you're here
so I'm asking you to pray I'm asking you
to pray for think media I'm asking you
to pray for me
pray for Omar pray for Nolan pray for
the content creators you follow pray for
and then pray for the people that you
follow on YouTube Pray for influence
pray like take prayer to a whole that
was the instruction
pray to the Lord who's in charge of the
Harvest and ask them to send more
workers in the field
pray for the the most subscribed
channels pray like we just need more
that's not the world I don't think
anyone's gonna argue that the world
needs more prayer but when you
Discerning get clear and this could be
the moment you do it I think this is my
world like I like this world of of
content create like I started thinking I
I get I get invited to speak at these
different events in the crater economy
and all this stuff and it's probably a
largely non-Christian community
it's done don't curse the darkness so
that's my thank God that I'm in this
community
and I love this community and I want to
see God's goodness and his love and his
kindness experienced by this community
so your prayer list for yourself and for
others I think that's a needed thing and
we need to take action
First Chronicles 12 32
from the tribe of issachar there were
200 leaders of the tribe and their
relatives number six we need to take
action all these men understood the
signs of the times and they knew the
best course of action Israel should take
one of my favorite Verses first
Chronicles 12 32 because the 12 tribes
of Israel all had different skill sets I
think that this is a particular skill
set that we need as Christian content
creators
two things that these leaders understood
they understood the signs of the times
and they knew the best course of action
Israel should take
what does that mean
we understand that television
consumption is going down and YouTube
consumption is going up we understand
that the number one platform being
watched in American families living
rooms right now more than Netflix and
Hulu and HBO Max is YouTube we
understand the signs of the times people
are spending more time on their phones
they're consuming more content it's this
whole other conversation about how
healthy that is or isn't
but we should be lighting a candle there
the signs of the times where is people's
attention where is the opportunity where
is the need we're also living in times
where there is record depression record
um loneliness record suicide record
we're living in a dark time
where there's never been more need for
Salt and Light man what's happening in
the times we're living in an era of a
lot of confusion
that's a vacuum for truth
they understood the science of the times
and then they knew what the best course
of action was to take
wisdom strategy how do we approach this
if you're a Christian business owner
wanting to use content understanding
where's modern marketing going
understanding how do I build a brand a
business and stand out in this
environment
not only also then recognizing the
opportunity or problems but then knowing
the solutions
and you might say well I don't know the
best course of action to take well that
would be the thing to pursue in prayer
and in learning and in Skilling up last
verse Isaiah 6 8.
I heard the voice of the Lord saying
whom shall I send and who will go for us
and I said here I am send me
I feel like this what's funny about this
is like sometimes we say I don't know if
I'm called to this which you should
certainly pray about because you may or
may not be but here's what I think is
fascinating about this verse
people you know it says many are called
fewer Chosen and too many Christians
misinterpret that verse to think
I'm just waiting to get called by God
here's how I understand it have you ever
moved moved Apartments removed houses
is there any worse thing in life than
movie
right like
your back hurts you got to pack up have
you ever helped a friend move and they
were so unready that you were so
frustrated because you showed up they're
like scrambling their stuff all over the
floor they haven't boxed everything up
you're judging them you're super upset
you don't want to be there and they're
like yeah come help me move and I'll
give you like uh you know some Mug Root
Beer and a Domino's Pizza you're like
that's a great deal I was gonna have an
entire Saturday to myself but Mug Root
Beer and Domino's Pizza
you sold me
what's funny about moving is if you call
your friends to like say hey will you
help me move
all of a sudden If someone knows you're
moving they see one caller ID they don't
answer right all of a sudden if someone
uh knows that it's moving day you call
them they go oh ah that's I think of a
thing I think that uh you have a family
thing or whatever
many are called
few are chosen so you call all your
friends who who gets to actually come
help you move anybody who says yes
I'm back
I don't know how long ago it's gone but
I hope you can hear me
so someone just goes
the call goes out the call goes out I'm
too busy I've got something to do I've
got something happening this week but as
soon as someone goes yeah I think I
could help but then it's like I choose
you you're on the team to help me move
today somebody else goes yeah I think I
can do it you're like you're chosen
that's what I kind of feel like is
happening here in Isaiah because you
know when he says I heard the voice of
the Lord saying whom shall I send
it it doesn't say
hey Isaiah will you go for us and he's
like oh yeah here I am it's like the
Lord is shouting who shall I send and
who will go for us and the cool thing is
Isaiah was listening
like he was willing it's like many are
called fewer Chosen and we get to be
debate theology all all the time it
could be all different backgrounds but I
I think that most of us would agree the
call has gone out the Great Commission
has gone out that that the the calling
is there so if you're doubting your
calling let this be a sign it's like the
Lord is saying yeah if you feel
the desires of your heart like I want to
express my creativity I want to share my
message I want to create content I want
to put something out in the world I want
to do this he's saying like hey who
shall I send who's going to go you can
say here I am
I mean send me
like Sean did you ever have a angel call
you to YouTube no and that'd be weird
and some things that anyways uh but
that'd be cool if that if that's what
happened to you I've seen though I've
had a lot of different God encounters
and a lot of different things that have
happened in my life
um but I don't have any
Audible Voice
but as I crack the word open and I began
to see God's revealed will in scripture
I just want to challenge you like a lot
of times the desires of your heart if
you feel pulled in a particular
direction it's like you go to a
bookstore which which section do you go
to
I don't go to gardening I don't even
really go to history you know I don't
really go to the children's book section
but now I do actually because I've got
kids but I go to like the self-help
personal development I go to the
business section so it's like there's
just certain ways that God has wired you
yet he's calling all of us he's like yo
who's gonna go who's gonna actually
start creating this Con who's going to
start this new YouTube kids app Niche
Channel with a particular type of who's
gonna go and Isaiah was like oh I'm glad
I heard you I'll go and I think that
that's the challenge for us as Christian
content creators we need to take action
the the Harvest isn't the problem the
workers are
we got to understand the signs of the
times and know the best course of action
to take
and the call is going out and it's an
open call the only reason few are chosen
is because a lot of people don't want to
come help you move they're like oh skip
the caller ID God's challenging me to
get out of my comfort zone oh God's
calling me to go move something heavy
oh I I wanted to just take my Saturday
off instead of sitting down editing
video forgetting to turn the mic on
being super frustrated reshooting the
video having my computer crash putting
it out there feeling super discouraged
because I don't like how I look on
camera I don't like how I sound what's
the point of doing this I uploaded the
video I only got seven views you know
what I'm not going to answer the call
anymore
many are called but few were chosen and
I really do believe that God has unique
gift sets niches channels and topics for
each of us
but most callings are going unanswered
a lot of people have said the best books
the best YouTube channels the best
albums the best records
the best businesses the best solutions
to problems you want to know where you
can find them in the graveyard
there were ideas in here
or a call in here
that never actually left
for someone stepping out and pressing
record
so I'm going to challenge you we need to
take action
hey if you got value today hit the like
button
if you got any questions put four or
five question marks before and after it
hey I appreciate some super chat I want
to support the message I really
appreciate you thanks for uh the Super
Chat I'm just seeing these
and uh there's a cycling one can I get
to it thank you so much Cohen cycling
really appreciate you uh thanks for the
love it did freeze and I'm back I hope
and if you oh here's another one too
thanks for all the love sign up for your
Facebook page
um
does Christian content pay the bills
that's a that's a good question uh yeah
I mean I think it really does like we're
living in an era where that that's a
whole nother touchy subject for another
one I won't even say touchy Christian's
money mindsets you know because there is
Jesus talks like more about money than
almost anything else there's a lot of
verses on money and of course greed is
very dangerous and uh and making money
the first thing but Jesus ultimate thing
would seek first the kingdom and all
these things will be added to you as
well I think that
um one of the things we'll be talking
about on the challenge that's coming up
is
is how to monetize and so we're going to
be talking about how to get your first a
thousand subscribers
um or your next and how to earn a
thousand dollars in multiple different
ways and so lots of
uh there is a real business model you
can build around you know any type of
channel thank you Mimi for the Super
Chat
thank you for being here smash like
um if you can you repost your question
if um
if you if you posted one for the younger
guys you don't have a lot of time to
record record what should we do
um
I think you should it's about priorities
it's about discipline and then it's
about choosing what you're going to
sacrifice
so number one you make it a priority and
what can you and put it on your calendar
number two you got to be disciplined
when you've got kids full-time work in
school it just takes more discipline to
not be like I don't feel like it you got
to summon that energy after work go on a
walk get hydrated crush a Red Bull if
you have to or do whatever and then
number three though is choose what
you're going to sacrifice because event
we only do have so much time in the day
but if you're like well I have to work
full time and I need to have my four
hours of video gaming and my four hours
of shows and then I need to work out and
then I need to do this and I just can't
find time for YouTube the question would
be what would you give up for a season
you know Dave Ramsey always says live
today like no one else so that later in
life you can live and give like no one
else
one of the things I'm most passionate
about especially for young people
um and you say you know for younger guys
I think
in your 20s if you live
with Fierce discipline and a high level
of sacrifice
it'll transform the rest of your life
so if you when everybody else just wants
to go and hang out or just wants to do
something that's not moving you towards
your goals and dreams of course be kind
of course be involved in community
but there's just so much in the data is
in whether it's gaming or time spent on
our phone not creating just time
scrolling or it's uh and not a gaming
YouTube channel because that's cool too
but are you just
gaming or are you building your brand
and following the thing that you feel
called to create I think that a lot of
us could benefit from the law of
sacrifice in order to go up you've got
to give up
um a lot of good questions and let me
know let me know your aha from this and
then let me know if you'd like me to do
videos like this in the future
um I would uh I would love your feedback
and
um I do have a meeting in just a few
minutes Sean thank you so much for the
message today my God use this to light a
fire in both new and existing content
creators I appreciate you Jesse's life
um
config media create an updated made for
kids video to help Christian content
creators yeah great added to the list
really good idea Michael says trying to
help the church I attend
we have no money to rent a space on
Sunday such powerful message though
how's a very small church with no money
or a real building
I think that um
there could be a difference Michael
between Church content
and like what I'm creating so I would do
what I'm doing
even if I was like a local church pastor
so
doing live Church well is a challenge
like it is
soundboard how are we pulling audio
broadcasting worship is a real like
mixing it properly if is it even good in
the room let alone good online
so I would stick with what you can
control with the level of Excellence
and don't stream church for example so
maybe and the content you create at
church could be social media and maybe
some pictures and some Instagram stuff
and some awareness but here's my point
think about what I'm doing you you have
a USB mic a camera a light and you are
the pastor or whoever could do a weekly
Bible study you could create a video
podcast you could so and this is a
controlled environment you don't want me
to sing so I'm it's not going to be I'm
not gonna do any worship videos like
that praise and worship is not going to
be happening right here
um it's a controlled environment
I can only do one my I can't have four
guests on in this exact situation I
could have four guests on on stream yard
really easy so so that's what I think
Michael uh my friend Brady Shearer from
Pro Church tools talks about
um
talks about this concept
um called the uh
the 167.
and there's a hundred and
68 hours in a week and most churches
only have influence in one of those
hours people come to church there's some
music some announcements Sacrament
whatever else
what do you do in the other 167. that's
the opportunity and the other 167 is
forget what I'm talking about this setup
YouTube shorts from your phone YouTube
shorts green screen reacting to culture
bringing biblical wisdom YouTube shorts
just literally from your smartphone
vertical video live streaming you could
bring guests on YouTube live now just
the same way as you can on Instagram
um social media content just from your
phone probably not in a Sunday morning
setup you could try to do it that there
as well plug in a wireless mic into
lightning port or USBC hook it up to
pastors you know shirt
film cut out Clips it really isn't about
your resources it is about your
resourcefulness in a major way so it's a
really good question so I hope some of
that stuff's helpful
yeah the 167. man and this is this
Christian content creators are called to
the 167 like oh one hour on Sunday is
good enough what
like we we are one hour in Sunday in the
word one hour not eight we're 28 minutes
in the word
20 minutes in worship
and then the rest of the week
we are being bombarded by news by
YouTube social media drama with your
in-laws you know like there's a need of
Christian content creators redeeming
edifying strengthening strengthen
encourage encourage and build up
prophetic there is a need for Christian
content creators to be pumping out
valuable content and I appreciate all
these questions
um I've got a transition here let me see
what what these guys are doing I should
probably jump off here
um and so smash like if you're getting
value and uh and if you want to if you
want to talk more about this but also
some specific tactics tube1k
challenge.com next week not this week
depending on when the replay is April
13th or something
um Thursday Friday Saturday three days
morning and evening sessions entirely
free it's all happening in a private
Facebook group to 1kchallenge.com link
in the description down below if you
want to register
um thank you so much for the Super Chat
and uh I really appreciate you David
yeah thank you for hitting like and
thank you for
um uh the Love Today everybody and
um
I would love any feedback I'm gonna be
able to go back and read this chat so if
you had any takeaways from today I would
love any aha moments you have if you
have any questions I'm gonna go back and
read all the chats or leave it even
better in the comments once the live
stream is over
um and if you have any ideas or topics
you'd love for me to cover I kind of
just wanted to put this out there and um
and so let me know your feedback I
appreciate you so much my name is uh
Sean Cannell this is the think media
podcast Channel subscribe if you're not
subscribed and if you haven't seen I did
a video actually about three Bible
verses every uh every content creator
should know no matter what your
background or believes I think you'll
love that video so click or tap the
screen screen to check it out uh send
you massive love and respect uh and we
will talk soon God bless